hello everyone and welcome to my first
ever jake's take where i talk about the
good the bad and the ugly of a newly
released game and let you know if you
should buy it or not i recently played
dimija on stream so i thought it'd be a
good game to start this series on
especially since it's been considered a
souls like from software game that's
been drawing comparisons to bloodborne
and sakiro and are people right in
comparing thiamisia to those two games
that i really consider masterpieces in
terms of thimesia's combat system it's
pretty much like mixing those two games
together and to put it bluntly it's
awesome diameter's combat system is fun
to learn plain and simple you have a
standard saber attack and a claw attack
that are meant to affect two different
health bars that every enemy in the game
has the normal health bar and the green
health bar staber attacks damage the
white bar claw attacks damage the green
bar pretty simple to understand very
difficult to master each enemy has a
different moveset that you'll have to
learn or this game will absolutely
destroy you it's not an easy game in the
beginning but you get used to the combat
very easily you can dodge attacks that
remind me of the dodging sidestep
mechanics of bloodborne or you can use
the more effective deflect mechanic that
reminds me a lot of sakiro that keeps
you playing aggressively which this game
highly favors if you were a fan of
sakura's skill tree then you'll be a
major fan of themes leveling and talent
trees leveling is very simple you can
increase your damage health or plague
status each level you put in will also
give you talent points to spend with all
kinds of different abilities these
include saber deflect dodge claw
feathers and strategies all of which
have different sub talents for you to
invest points into the cool part is you
can move these talents around whenever
you want to create different character
builds on the fly without having to
stress too much on the talents that you
pick in the moment when you hold down
the claw ability you can steal away claw
attacks from enemies to use against them
you can also find or learn your own
special claw attacks that you can equip
to your character to have every time you
deflect an enemy you've also got your
potions that are just your general
healing abilities there's three
different kinds of healing to choose
from short long and fast healing i
really never felt it necessary to change
from the base healing potions and just
upgraded that to make it better but
having the options for players to
customize even their healing abilities
is pretty cool to put it short the
combat system is fun to learn it runs
deep with customization and it's very
addictive to try and master the flow of
combat is the true meat of this game
which is why i'm not worried about
showing you guys any spoilers the
experience is in the gameplay even with
the sometimes janky mechanics that can
get stuck in walls from time to time i
still had a ton of fun playing this game
the boss fights are creative
entertaining and learning their move
sets reminds me of any souls game i've
ever played the one gimmick boss i came
across was the worst boss i've ever
experienced in any game ever even worse
than the bet of chaos in my opinion but
once you get through it you never have
to do it again however the main bosses
and even most of the side bosses are
amazing my fight against old took me
over an hour to beat and i loved every
second of it the payoff was totally
worth it and gave me flashbacks of the
first time i ever played any souls game
and the best part of it is this boss is
completely optional that boss was so
cool so well designed so pretty with
beautiful animations with beautiful
soundtrack in the back that's a s tier
boss
so cool so much fun to learn great
payoff after doing it freaking sick
however where thinesha falls short is
just the overall story there's no voice
acting and a ton of reading and most of
it is pretty basic posters or notes that
give you a bit of lore about the area
maybe an upcoming boss and sometimes the
overall point of the game you can also
beat this game in less than four hours
if you just fly through all the main
areas i'd say there's an additional
eight hours of optional content for you
to play which includes one of the best
boss fights i've ever played and also
one of the worst so the optional stuff
can be pretty hit or miss especially
since the other optional areas are just
destroying or finding certain items now
there is definitely a story here and the
atmosphere of each level is pretty cool
but i didn't really care enough to learn
it at least for me the story here i
didn't take much interest in but when i
learned this game was made by a
development team of less than 10 people
i really just let everything slide and
played the game for what it was so was
it worth the 20 i paid for the game
absolutely are you going to get more
than one playthrough out of this game
you could there's some replayability in
the way you can build your character but
other than that you likely will only
play through this game once i can
definitely see players speed running
this game trying to beat all the bosses
as fast as possible that could be really
cool nymeja is a good game with an
amazing combat system that you should
play if you have the means to do so for
myself i was really surprised how much i
enjoyed it once i got deeper into the
game i was addicted to the flow of
combat in less than an hour and i felt
like the price of admission was worth
every penny thank you all for watching
let me know if you'd like to see more
jake's takes videos like this do all the
nice youtube stuff to help you grow the
channel if you want to and i will see
you all in the next video take care